il ya une montée comme ça progressif du
désir dans le film parce que la scène de
cul n'arrive qu'à la moitié du film un
mois j'ai regardé j'étais là je suis
attendait tous âges et tant mieux alors
lancez vous êtes bien content elle est
très torride la scène vraiment ouais il
ya un truc c'est que votre peau et est
constamment humide à cause de la chaleur
du du laboratoire comme ça c'est très
excitant très très excitant sema show ce
soir
les gens n'arrêtent pas de baiser chose
dans ce huitième comme c'est la première
fois qu'on se voie oui on va faire une
interview première alors votre premier
souvenir
ma grand mère qui m'apporte un verre de
lait avec des deux gâteaux les deux
gueules soir votre premier choc choc à
quoi une voiture m'a renversé
vous aviez que l'âge de 11 ans votre
premier mensonge non musulmans tout le
temps allez je vais
c'est jamais fait renverser par une
femme est votre premier péché alors
faire l'amour qu'elle est mignonne
contenant votre premier coup de foudre
jamais jamais jusqu'à maintenant c'est
vrai qu'avant il faisait cette émission
avec moi et heureusement que tu n'es
plus là tu ils cassent tous les coups il
est jaloux peuvent que j'ai embrassé sur
la bouche et blanc je m'intéresse à
quelqu'un on ne casse pas tous les coups
la première jeune fille 6 13 07 sur la
bouche sans la langue
c'était à vous savez les camps s'appelle
aller les campagnards comme avant ça
existait mais j'étais dans un jeu mais
jeudi avoir 10 coûte 10 10 ans on en
était là bas et le premier baiser avec
la langue
c'est avec ce garçon de l'allemand cours
de danse le premier flirt poussé avec un
garçon un flirt poussé enfin vous
appreniez les termes le flirt poussé
alors qu'est ce que c'est enfin le
repousser et ce depuis lors avec la même
carte peut montrer
c'était déjà poussé sa flore poussées
ont fait naître sauve tout voilà a
toujours le même
votre première expérience homosexuelle
ça y est je savais pas de raison merde
c'est un sacré je n'ai pas de combien
fois à troyes ces programmes si c est
pas moi à peu près vingt dix chez vous
première fois quatre à je regardais
premier chagrin d'amour
oui peut-être j'avais 15 ans on a besoin
d'un garçon qui était mon succès le
danseur c'est vrai j'étais triste mais
bon c'est pas un chagrin parce que comme
il ya jamais eu au début c'était pas
vous avez vous avez des races et vous
allez un peu froide avec tout ça a pas
l'air de vraiment vous passionnez wendy
sentimentale que ça moi comment pourtant
vous êtes scorpionvous non oui on a très
bien et les scorpions seb le sexe quand
même je vous trouve très non j'ai campé
dans laquelle vous êtes sentimentale
quand même sentimental je me demande si
sentimentale que salga finalement
peut-être de temps en temps des fois ça
dépend vous n'êtes pas amoureuse en ce
moment un bon déjà et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de 1h10 tube abonnez vous
y mettez un peu de bleu